bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur
téléphiles 60,18 votre rendez vous
quotidien avec l information locale en
direct si vous nous rejoignez à 18h pour
débuter cette édition un hommage à
stéphane hessel disparu aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 95 ans est né allemand arrivé
en france à l'âge de 8 ans il aura été
résistant aura survécu aux camps de
concentration avant de devenir diplomate
et de participer à la rédaction de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme à plusieurs reprises stéphane
hessel est venue dans le département des
yvelines la dernière fois c'était en
2011 à l'université de versailles saint
quentin afin d'échanger avec les
étudiants de la filière de droit peu de
temps auparavant il publié le manifeste
indignez-vous à destination des jeunes
générations un manifeste vendu à 4
millions d'exemplaires à travers le
monde
inlassablement il répétait le même
message ce que je me prépare à faire
c'est à donner confiance et courage à
une génération de français qui vivent
dans un monde difficile dans un monde
plein de problèmes mal résolu pour le
moment angoissant certains mais qu'il
faut aborder avec la conviction qu'avec
un peu de courage et un peu de dynamisme
on doit pouvoir réaliser un monde plus
juste
stéphane hessel était aussi le parrain
du carré de mémoire le lieu de mémoire
de magny les hameaux un lieu de
rencontres et d'échangés entre les
générations en plein centre ville et qui
permet de ne pas oublier les conflits
armés du passé je vous propose justement
d'écouter le maire de la ville à cette
époque gel que l'odieuse nous l'avons
contacté cet après-midi pour qu'il nous
fasse part de ce qu'il ressentait à
l'annoncé de la disparition de stéphane
hessel
pour moi ils voient de mémoire qui
s'éteint et très franchement qu'ils
vivent encore dans une génération qui ne
connaissent pas la persécution des deux
régions des conflits tu pouvais le pied
posé les peuples européens
et c'est vrai qu'on fait bien que dans
ce type de situation la méconnaissance
et et le widom engendré donc
automatiquement
c'est donc sur ça que vous soyez avec la
la perte de 2,7 en effet comme on
appelle lui aussi donc mon bras s'est
auparavant et sur oise c'est un homme
très vif très intelligente oncle qui
connaissait parfaitement son sujet très
ouvert donc très gentil aussi mais lui
et son épouse étaient donc à mes côtés
et c'est vrai que c'est des gens simples
les gens simples malgré sa notoriété il
dégageait donc beaucoup de simplicité il
allait auprès des enfants donc il me
parle être tout à fait l'angle d'une
manière tout à fait donc simple donc
non c'est vraiment quelqu'un d'attachant
très franchement quelqu'un attachant qui
qui avait beaucoup de mails contacts ça
c'est que là il aimait contacts facebook
est ce qu'il le ferait donc vivre
voilà pour cette réaction de jacques
lolliot de l'ancien maire de magny les
hameaux qu'il avait rencontré stéphane
hessel et lors de sa venue à magny les
hameaux il avait aussi échanger avec les
enfants lors d'un forum des jeunes
citoyens un échange qu'il avait
particulièrement apprécié et qui lui
avait permis aussi de revenir sur ses
positions sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien et jan poser des
questions intelligentes et intéressante
on a parlé de la résistance en a parlé
de la guerre on a parlé du monde et ils
se sentent tous ensemble c'est
merveilleux grande satisfaction pour moi
je reviens de là bas j'ai été plusieurs
fois à gaza et gt est friable ce qui s'y
passe il faut que nous ayons le même
esprit que ses enfants
nous sommes tous citoyens du monde voilà
pour cet échange avec stéphane hessel
c'était en 2009 je vous le disais ces
quelques mots que nous avons souhaité
lui consacrer en sa mémoire nous passons
à présent aux titres de l'actualité du
jour les sujets que nous allons
développer au cours de cette édition du
7 8
les chiffres du chômage ne sont pas bons
au plan national ils sont également
mauvais sur le plan départemental sur un
mois à noter une progression du nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi de 2,3 pour cent
alors que cette hausse n'est que de 1,4
pour cent pour la france à l'industrie
automobile est la première touchée
pendant deux à trois semaines les
usagers de la ligne lui entre la
verrière et la défense sont privés de
train les voyageurs prennent leur mal en
patience la sncf de son côté multiplié
les sources d'information une expérience
originale menée au technocentre renault
de guyancourt pendant une semaine
l'entreprise accueille des jeunes élèves
de 3e du collège courbet de trappes pour
leur montrer différents métiers des
collaborateurs sont spécialement
missionnée pour organiser ces rencontres
et nous en parlerons d'ailleurs en
plateau dans un instant et puis le
nouveau café de la plage de maurepas qui
s'apprête à accueillir son traditionnel
festival chaud l'hiver l'occasion de
faire le point avec la structure et
n'oubliez pas en seconde partie de cette
édition du 7 8 à la chronique culture
dans une vingtaine de minutes avec
aurélia de bissy de nombreuses
découvertes musicales
au programme mais avant la culture l
économie et ses collégiens donc en
immersion du côté du technocentre à
guyancourt